hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute in meinem video geht es um
das thema kinderwagen ich möchte euch
heute endlich mal ein kinderwagen zeigen
ich hatte es ja schon länger versprochen
weil einfach schon ganz wieder danach
gefragt hatten
samira zeigt übrigens und bei mir was du
als ich damals auch bei der samira ihm
schwanger war
wofür genau vor fünf jahren damals hat
sich immer so lange her an was natürlich
so wenn man schwanger ist dann kennt es
wahrscheinlich viele von euch auch da
informiert man sich dann gleich mal was
brauche ich denn überhaupt alles fürs
kind
und da sitzt man eben so dass im dritten
vierten monat und stück hat die
internetseiten durchschaut sich in baby
shops um und schaut einfach mal was
brauche ich als ich brauche dich
brauchen kinderwagen
ich brauch keine ahnung angesprochen wie
immer viel zu viel fürs kind da komme
ich aber noch am ende darauf zu sprechen
und auch bei der samira damals war es
ebenso ich habe dann gesagt okay wir
brauchen einen kinderwagen eigentlich
ganz komisch dass man immer zuerst einen
kinderwagen denkt stadt irgendwie ans
babybett aber es war halt da auch so ich
meistens der zweite satz ja ich bin
schwanger sondern ich vom kinderwagen
genau und zusammengetragen
ja auf jeden fall habe ich mich damals
daneben auch im internet informiert das
geht ja heutzutage zum glück ganz gut
man kann natürlich ganz viele seiten
durchforsten es gibt so viele anbieter
es gibt so viele hersteller und da geht
es natürlich auch ganz viele bewertungen
drüber ganz viele meinungen und ganz
viele tests und da war es dann am ende
irgendwie so ich war eigentlich total
überfordert weil ich nicht mehr wusste
was brauche ich jetzt leben glaube ich
jetzt und was hole ich mir jetzt am ende
und bei uns was eben damals so wir waren
beide noch studenten also morath und ich
und da muss man natürlich auch gucken
dass es jetzt nicht zu teuer werde eine
ausbildungsstelle
denn man muss ja auch schauen was kann
man sich überhaupt leisten aber dennoch
haben wir halt damals auch schon wert
darauf legt dass es halt so was
qualitatives wird deswegen habe ich mich
damals für einen kinderwagen entschieden
zu einem kombi kinderwagen da war dann
der sportwagen mit dabei die babyschale
mit dabei und sogar noch ein autos sitzt
was hat richtig toll war weil ich hab
gedacht habe okay damit macht stand ein
schnäppchen
wobei schnäppchen auch also wären
trotzdem ich glaube ungefähr 400 euro
ausgegeben was natürlich schon relativ
viel ist für jemanden da studiert und
jemanden der in der ausbildung ist 800 x
ja mag rechnet wir jetzt nicht mehr auf
jeden fall haben wir dann den
kinderwagen damals bekommen und das
erste war als ich ihn ausgesagt habe
er hat einfach furchtbar gestunken also
das war wirklich ich weiß nicht ob du
dich noch daran erinnert aber er hat
furchtbar gestunken nach ich weiß nich
emi nach chemie nach gift ich weiß es
war wirklich furchtbar
deswegen habe ich dann erstmal alle
bezüge abgenommen und gewaschen und als
es danach immer noch nicht besser wurde
habe ich ihn einfach im monat auf der
terrasse stehen lassen weil ich hab den
ja schon während der schwangerschaft
gekauft und konnte dann einfach draußen
stehen lassen
dort steht ja immer noch dort stehen sie
eigentlich immer noch der geruch wurde
leider wieder zeitlich besser aber wir
hatten denen dann schon und ich konnte
dann auch nicht mehr reklamieren ich
hatte den nämlich im internet bestellt
und die haben sich geweigert den
kinderwagen zurückzunehmen
also mussten wir dann halt behalten haar
gekommen so ein bisschen lüften dann
geht's auf jeden fall
leider war das aber nicht der einzige
macken an dem kinderwagen denn es war
leider auch so dass der allgemeinheit
nicht so qualitativ war
obwohl nicht gedacht habt das war
eigentlich schon so eine marke wo man
denkt ich will es jetzt auch nicht
schlecht machen aber es war eine marke
wo man denkt okay das sollte einem schon
guter kinderwagen seien und die marke
hat sich seit deutschland gehört das war
sehr sehr dollar
leider ist naja haben jetzt dazu gelernt
auf jeden fall war es dann halt auch so
der kinderwagen hat zwar ein sehr
leichtes gestellt aber es halt ziemlich
billig verarbeitet sage ich jetzt mal
was sagen anfang man sich halt nicht
erkennt man sich nicht auf die räder
waren zum beispiel richtig klein und es
waren auch keine luft räder sondern zum
beispiel nur so so hartgummi räder und
auch allgemein wenn man mit dem wagen
gefahren ist da kommt man nicht richtig
lenken weil die rede dass ich immer
wieder verdreht haben und das ging
einfach nicht mehr
und nach zwei wochen ist mir sogar das
gestell kaputt gegangen also nach zwei
wochen fahren und ich hab den dann
reklamiert abkommen jetzt möchte ich ihn
zurückschicken das kaputte ist
unbrauchbar
und die haben mir das geld nicht
zurückgeschickt werden neue stelle
geschickt war natürlich das problem
nicht gelöst denn dann hatte ich ein
neues gestell was natürlich wieder nach
ein paar monaten einfach abgenommen
war und ich den wagen wieder nicht
benutzen konnte und das war eigentlich
auch das problem warum ich jetzt am ende
neun kinderwagen gebraucht habe für die
ella weil ursprünglich war mein gedanke
beim ersten kind kaufe ich meinen
kinderwagen und den benutzt dann einfach
für alle meine kinder haben geringere 45
stück ja auf jeden fall war das leider
damals nicht so
deswegen musste jetzt ein neuer
kinderwagen her der murat hat das ganze
irgendwie vergessen und hat gesagt nee
wir brauchen keine neuen kinderwagen wir
nehmen einfach den alten will der
weinkeller und ich hab dann ewig mit ihm
diskutieren ich meine findet es immer
ganz lustig wieder mit mir diskutiert
aber wenn man mit dem mann zusammenlebt
und dem einfach nicht klar machen kann
dass der kinderwagen wirklich
unbrauchbar war dann war das schon
ziemlich anstrengend und ich habe mir am
ende dann doch überzeugen können dass
wir einen neuen kinderwagen brauchen als
wir den keller ausgemistet haben und in
alten kinderwagen gesehen hat und er hat
gesagt okay hast recht das stimmt
übrigens immer noch
und da stehe ich immer noch fünf jahren
das ist wirklich unglaublich
also nicht nur wir riechen sondern auch
meine mama hat gesagt mein gott wie
konnten wir den damals überhaupt
benutzen also wirklich ganz schlimm
minuten der ja eigentlich hast ja das
ist ja eines wollte ich den sachspenden
das flüchtlingsheim wir haben aber einen
corner werden dann anrufe bekommen ob
jemand auch einen kinderwagen hat und
als wir dann aber ausgepackt haben habe
ich sagte also wenn mein kind da nicht
drin wegen kann dann will ich auch nicht
dass ein anderes kind drin liegen muss
deswegen einfach wegschmeißen ich heiße
weg obwohl es sehr gut ist ein trauriger
ja ich traurig na ja meine mutter hatte
übrigens ganz sagen wir gerade über geld
ausgeben sind ja meine mutter ist ganz
einfach gemacht also als wir im
schwabenland waren wir haben einfach
einen einkaufswagen beim aldi geklaut
was geklaut haben d mark für eine dem
anger nicht mein euro also angenommen
mit stroh ausgelegt und fertig der
schwäbische kinder war genau dieselben
schwäbische version des kinder war ja
zum glück ist heutzutage nicht mehr so
und es gibt auch gute kinderwagen
hersteller und deswegen haben wir uns
natürlich auch dieses mal wieder
informieren müssen
natürlich habe ich dann falls ihr euch
erinnert in einem schwangerschafts
update euch gefragt und gefragt welchen
kinderwagen könnt ihr mir empfehlen und
es wurden wirklich sehr viele marken
genannt aber die häufigste marke die
genannt wurde war eigentlich der vater
und bisher hat er mir die marke nichts
gesagt als ich kannte hart haben den
kinderwagen hersteller nicht und habe
mich dann einfach mal informiert und ich
habe sogar eine e-mail bekommen von
einer zuschauerin deren mann dort
arbeitet sich dann auch ganz witzig also
habe ich gedacht kommt jetzt schaut mal
auf die seite vorbei und dann sind wir
auch zu einem baby fachmarkt gefahren
und haben uns dann einfach mal angeguckt
und ich war also als ich schwanger waren
auch zeitgleich zwei andere freundinnen
schwanger von mir
und die haben dann beide gesagt ja wir
haben den auch schon gekauft also beide
von den hatten auch ein harter und sogar
unsere nachbarin die hat auch einen
harten die gegenüber sie aber das fiel
uns alles erst auf als wir uns selber
damit beschäftigt haben genau wenn du
schwanger bist dann merkst du plötzlich
auch gott die ganze umgebung ist
schwanger und wenn du dir dann den
kinderwagen holen möchte schmeckst du
ach gott alle haben den gleichen
kinderwagen
also haben wir uns darüber informiert
und was ich richtig toll fand hart
anhört sich auch sehr deutschland und es
ist auch wirklich eine deutsche firma
also sie klingt nicht nur durch sie ist
deutsch
und mir hat er ganz gut gefallen dass
sie wirklich alles zu 100 prozent in
deutschland produzieren als es wert hier
konstruiert dass wir tätig sein und es
wird hier produziert und hier verkauft
so ein hund zu 100 prozent und das hat
mich so fasziniert weil ich für eine
heutzutage gibt es echt noch wenig
firmen die wirklich alles zu 100 prozent
hier produzieren es gibt natürlich auch
hersteller da steht dann drauf designed
in germany
aber die produzieren dann halt nicht in
deutschland die produzieren dann
meistens halt eben fernost und ich meine
für mich macht es keinen unterschied ob
jetzt deutschland österreich oder
schweiz sind für mich oder frankreich
das sind für mich natürlich länder denen
ich dann vertraue also dass da eben
sicherheitskriterien erfüllt werden und
die standards erfüllt werden aber wenn
ich halt weiß das produkt wird kommt
dann eben aus fernost weiß ich eben wie
bei den textilien zum beispiel das
können dann schadstoffe drin sein
chemikalien drin sein
uns wird dort hat einfach nicht so
kontrolliert wie bei uns hier und
deswegen war mir das eben ganz wichtig
und deswegen haben wir uns dann eben
beide über den harten informiert uns den
angeschaut und letztendlich dann eben
auch angeschafft
wichtig ist mir natürlich beim einem
kinderwagen zuerst mal die sicherheit
also neben den schadstoffen natürlich
auch die sicherheit
und dafür ist zb das tüv unternehmen
zuständig also auf den weg sind
kinderwagen den man kaufen kann ist
wirklich ein titel drauf und mein
kinderwagen der hat es wirklich mit
auf das war mir ganz wichtig deswegen
könnt ihr mal bei euch auf einem
kinderwagen schauen ob er überhaupt
einen tüv siegel drauf habt das ist für
mich halt wirklich so im
sicherheitskriterium als sie die werden
ja geprüft nach der europäischen
sicherheitsnorm en 1888 ist das genau
und da könnte auf jeden fall mal schauen
im internet gibt natürlich ganz viele
tests zeiten die kinderwagen und so
weiter alles testen also mal findet er
wirklich zahlreiche seiten und ich finde
wenn eine testseite kinderwagen testet
und bin dann gleichzeitig auch verkauft
wenig salz ziemlich unseriös also man
weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht was man
glauben soll vor allem scheidet der eine
kinderwagen bei test gut ab beim anderen
test schneidet der mangelhaft ab man
muss man halt einfach immer hinterfragen
was wurde denn gerade getestet wurden
dass nur die reifen getestet wurden die
schadstoff getestet die firma allgemein
getestet die sicherheit getestet also
man muss es halt immer hinterfragen und
deswegen finde ich es halt immer ganz
wichtig weil man ebenso testzeiten
eigentlich nicht wirklich vertrauen kann
dass man einfach sagt okay ich nehme ein
regionales unternehmen die erfüllten die
sicherheitskriterien die standards und
dann weiß ich zum beispiel auch wenn es
in deutschland und in österreich oder in
der schweiz oder vor ort eben produziert
wird weiß ich auch es kommen gar nicht
diese schadstoffe mit rein
und deswegen haben wir uns jetzt
schlussendlich für den harten
kinderwagen entschieden und ich hab ja
sogar angerufen weil ich ja wusste alles
wird er in deutschland produziert habe
gedacht komm ich fahr mal hin und film
das für euch aber leider wurde mir da
abgesagt also privat dürfte man
eventuell hin um da in die produktion
mit rein zu schauen aber filmen darf man
es natürlich nicht geholt ein auf die
sendung mit der maus wollte ich zeigen
ja ich finde es auch als ich für mich
ist auch ganz klar verständlich dass da
eine firma sagt okay wir schützen unsere
produktion und unsere geheimnisse
deswegen finde ich das völlig okay ja
und ich würde sagen ich sage nicht
einfach mal kurz mein kinderwagen für
welches modell ich mich entschieden habe
und wasser halt so alles karten hatten
die auch angst vor mir
also denkt kinderwagen gibt es in
verschiedenen ausführungen da gibt es
auch verschiedene modelle
ich habe mir jetzt halt den ihr
ausgesucht das ist der vip und ich hab
da oben
diese kombi tasche mit dabei also da
gibt es auch verschiedene und ich habe
mir dieses schöne hellgrau ausgesucht
einfach weil ich neutral halten
und diese tragetasche da oben die kann
man hier ganz einfach ab machen
an beiden seiten und die muss man halt
zusammen mit dem sportwagen aufsatz
benutzen
und da kann ich diese tasche rausnehmen
inclusive ist ein jahr als puppe
natürlich der zähne freuen reingelegt
und dann kann ich das so zum beispiel
auch transportieren wir mal nach dem
spaziergang zu besuch gehen habe ich das
mit rein nehmen und die ela kann einfach
drin weiter schlafen und dann habe ich
hier diesen sportwagen aufsatz dem
benutzt man ja erst ab sechs monaten
also bis sechs monate schläft sie unten
in der tasche und ab sechs monaten hat
sie dann eben hier diesen sportwagen
aufsatz und der muss halt unten immer
mit dabei sein bei dieser tasche einfach
aus sicherheitsgründen falls man zum
beispiel mit kinderwagen irgendwie durch
den supermarkt läuft und man würde
zweifel gegen den regal laufen dann muss
natürlich so eine gewisse stabilität der
seine sicherheit dass eben das regal
sich zum beispiel nicht zum kind durch
drückt das hat der kinder bank von außen
schön stabil ist und bei dem sportwagen
aufsatz hatten halt dieses verdeckt mit
dabei
das kann man hier eben regeln und man
kann natürlich auch die höhe über
stellen also dass das kind dann später
praktisch auch sitzen kann und es kann
man dann eben auch wieder zurückstellen
und hier vorne da habe ich so zwei
aufhängen da kann ich meine wickeltasche
aufregen und einfach auch wieder weg
machen und das finde ich halt auch super
weil dann habe ich da unten den korb
einfach frei um zum beispiel samira
sache noch mit zu transportieren oder
wenn ich mal in der stadt unterwegs bin
auf markt kann ich da einfach ein paar
sachen mit rein machen und was für mich
auch ganz wichtig ist ich kann da oben
den griff einstellen also da könne große
menschheit ist ganz groß machen und
etwas kleinere einfach kleiner und man
kann sich einfach anpassen und muss
nicht irgendwie gebückt mit dem
kinderwagen laufen und das finde ich
halt hier oben ganz gut hier unten habe
ich die bremse also die kann ich einfach
mit dem fuß sichern und dann auch wieder
lösen und so ist einfach der kinderwagen
vom wegrollen gesichert was noch für die
sicherheit beiträgt sind hier diese
reflektoren also damit kann man dann
eben auch abends spazieren gehen und die
autofahrer sehen ich dann eben trotzdem
der hat an beiden seiten die reflektoren
und hier oben zb auch also wirklich an
mehreren stellen
und ich habe hier einen ganz leichten
rahmen das zeige ich euch mal ganz kurz
es in alu rahmen und ich kann gezielt
diesen sportwagen aufsatz einfach so
raus nehmen und zum beispiel dann ins
auto stellen das zeigen sich dann gleich
noch also ihr seht die montage und auch
das weg nämlich ganz einfach auch zum
draufsetzen muss ich ihnen einfach
wieder drauf klicken so einfach an
beiden seiten
und dann ist ja schon wieder fest und
hier im innern des sportwagens hat man
dieses fünf punkte kurz system und man
kann es dann eben auch einstellen je
nachdem wie großes kindes als am anfang
etwas kleiner später etwas größer und
dann hat man eben da auch die sicherheit
wenn das kind da drin sitzt hier den fuß
teil kann man natürlich auch vorstellen
je nach größe des kindes und dieses
verdeck kann man dann eben auch öffnen
und schließen
und das schützt das kind eben auch vor
der sonne aber auch allgemein schützt
der bezug von der sonneneinstrahlung mit
50 plus
aber man soll das kind ja natürlich
trotzdem nicht der direkten sonne
aussetzen und deswegen halt immer diese
dieses verdeck eben aufklappen und der
zusammenbau geht halt wirklich sehr
einfach also wenn man den sportwagen
aufsatz weggenommen
inklusive tragetasche dann ist es
eigentlich noch ganz leicht man hat hier
die feststellbremse die habe ich es fest
gedrückt dann drehe ich hier oben vaters
ein und da muss man einfach nur noch
hier drücken umzuklappen und kann es
dann einfach so transportieren und es
ist halt wirklich sehr einfach als
selbst für mich für mich als frau ist es
sehr einfach das zu tragen weil es
einfach dieses adlergestell ist und so
habe ich dann auch im auto nicht so viel
platz verbraucht und kann es einfach
schön reinstellen und aufbau geht
genauso einfach was ich halt bei dem
auch richtig genial finde diese
flexibilität also die räder vorne sind
total flexibel und ich kann das ding
eigentlich komplett einmal um sich herum
drehen das ging mit meinem alten
kinderwagen gar nicht arbeit zeige ich
euch noch ganz kurz wenn ich schon dabei
wenn die reifen und zwar sind es ja hier
richtige reifen das heißt ich hab ja
auch luft drin und es ist nicht so ein
hartgummi sah man ist ein richtiger
luftreifen und die haben halt auch eine
tolle federung das heißt wenn ich auch
mal über so ein feldweg laufe dann
wackelt das kinder drin nicht so sondern
der kinderwagen federt das richtig gut
ab und wenn ihr den jetzt
zusammengeklappt habt und der trotzdem
ein bisschen viel platz im auto
verbraucht er weniger platz im auto habt
oder mal ein einkauf noch mit drin habt
könnt ihr die räder auch einfach
wegnehmen und zwar einfach hier per
knopfdruck und könnt dann die räder eben
separat aufbewahren und dann einfach
wieder drauf und vorne geht es genauso
da kann ich die räder auch ganz einfach
wegnehmen und dann eben separat
aufbewahren und mit einem klick sind sie
dann wieder drauf und wenn man möchte
kann man die räder vorne dann auch
einfach feststellen also arretieren das
macht man einfach hier an der seite und
dann sind sie eben nicht mehr flexibel
sondern fahren daneben nur noch
geradeaus und wenn man die räder
abmontiert hat dann sieht das ganze so
aus dann habe ich hier die vier räder
das gestell was wirklich sehr flach ist
und dann eben nur noch diesen
kinderwagen aufsatz also den sportwagen
aufsatz mit der tasche und ich zeige
euch jetzt einfach mal wie ich das alles
im kofferraum verstauen
jetzt kann ich es einfach einstellen das
ist übrigens nicht unser auto sondern
dass wir unserem freund unser auto
kriegt nämlich kathi winterreifen drauf
aber das tut auch also einfach hinten
rein
bei uns kann das glaube ich so etwas
hoch stellen wir unser kofferraum
negativ ist sondern etwas höher
und dann eben noch das gestellt und wenn
wir jetzt erstmal im auto sind sie noch
ganz kurz den autositz als kindersitz
habe ich hier einen maxi cosi und da
habe ich im auto drin hier so eine
station und zwar gibt es verschiedene
ausführungen und ich habe leider die
falsche ausführung bestellt und zwar
gibt es eine die macht man mit dem iso
fix fest das ist dann hinten am sitzen
ist also zwei teile die man dann eben
festklemmt ich habe jetzt die version
mit dem gurt also habt ihr mit dem gurt
befestigt und unten ist da eben noch
seinen fuß der da unten auf sitzen muss
und die finde ich ganz praktisch denn
man kann einfach den autositz dann
nehmen und hier rein klicken
und was ich da auch noch ziemlich
praktisch finde ist dieser auf
dieser adapter da kann es nämlich
einfach den maxi cosi drauf machen dann
kann ich zum beispiel damit einfach
einkaufen fahren wenn nicht ganz kurz
nur unterwegs bin muss nicht den ganzen
kinderwagen auspacken und zum abmachen
drücke ich dann einfach diese zwei
knöpfe hier
also ihr habt jetzt einfach mal meinen
kinderwagen gesehen um einen autositz
und natürlich gibt's wirklich solche
kataloge an babyzubehör was muss ich
alles kaufen sollte kaufen muss aber ich
bin das gewächs nur eine handvoll dinge
die man wirklich braucht dazu zählt für
mich einfach der kinderwagen der autos
sitzt der hochstuhl und eigentlich das
bett das sind wirklich so viele
grundlegende dinge die man wirklich
braucht
alles andere finde ich brauche
eigentlich nicht wirklich oder morath
und ich meine familie weiter sie uns ist
dass die person natürlich darauf an wer
mit schon das zweite kind und wir haben
wirklich nicht alles gebraucht und ich
denke bei gewissen sachen gerade bei den
vier dingen die ich aufgezählt habe
sollten halt wirklich wert auf qualität
legen und vor allem auf die sicherheit
weil gerade zum beispiel hochschulen
autos sitzen kinderwagen solche dinge
müssen einfach sicher sein und
qualitativ sein
ich würde euch auf jeden fall gerne noch
einen ausstattungs video zeigen also
auch mein baby bett und mein hochschul
zum beispiel wenn euch das interessiert
und ich finde zum beispiel dass man
viele sachen einfach auf second and
holen kann
das heißt gut beim ersten kind denkt mal
was muss alles neu sein es muss alles
schön sein ich kriege zum ersten mal das
erste kind aber ich finde dass man da
eher wert auf qualität setzt und sagt
okay vielleicht kann ich nicht so viel
geld ausgeben dann kauf ich mir lieber
was qualitativ ist aus dem second hand
laden oder vom kinderflohmarkt oder ich
habe zum beispiel auch ganz viele
kleidung von meinen freundinnen
abgekauft die einfach schon ältere
kinder hatten und es finde ich eben ganz
wichtig vor allem kann man so einfach
die ganzen produkte immer so im lauf
lassen also dann müssen sie auch nicht
entsorgt werden und kommen 1 8-fachen er
nur einfachen nenner und was ich ganz
wichtig findet dass man gerade diese
großen anschaffungen nur im fachhandel
macht also ich hab jetzt gerade wieder
ich weiß ich sagte immer selber aber wer
mit zum beispiel diese station für den
maxi cosi autos sitzt auch im internet
bestellt und ich habe gesagt ich wollte
eigentlich den mit der isofix station
hab es leider im internet bestellt und
erst vier wochen später bemerkt das ist
der berg unseren unsere frau oder
freundin für mich ich habe selber gar
nicht gemerkt ich dachte immer isofix
den macht man doch gar nicht da fest auf
jeden fall hätte ich so einfach mark
gekauft hätte ich den eben auch noch mal
austauschen können aber im internet war
wohl zu spät genau ausprobieren auf
jeden fall gerade beim kinderwagen finde
ich müsste
mit einem auto hinfahren denn dann
können wir direkt ausprobieren ob der
kinderwagen reinpasst auch beim auto
sitzt muss man direkt ausprobieren ob
der autos jetzt gut reinpasst deswegen
fange jetzt auch immer gut die beratung
war super
das solltet ihr auch machen ja einfach
die ganzen funktionen die matratzen
steht man da mit dem handbuch was man
natürlich trotzdem lesen sollte aber
weiß einfach nicht wirklich ok wo fange
ich an wo ich auf sicherheit ist es
wichtig ich will als kind sehr oft
hingefallen sind
ich merke ich sagen zeigen wir euch
gleich noch das kinderwagen bzw
sie zeigt den euch das ist ziemlich
witzig geworden und ich hoffe dass euch
dieses video gefallen hat falls jetzt
jemand sagt du hast einen kinderwagen ja
jetzt erst fünf wochen in gebrauch kann
ja auch sein dass er jetzt demnächst
kaputtgeht ich habe eigentlich keine
bedenken denn ich habe die ganzen
kommentare von meinen zuschauern gelesen
und stand wirklich oft darin dass da
wirklich schon fünf kinder den harten
kinderwagen benutzt haben der schon über
mehrere jahre in gebrauch ist der
unterlack auch schon der opa lag auch
schon drin deswegen habe ich dafür keine
bedenken
also das fand ich ganz faszinierend auf
jeden fall wünsche euch ganz viel spaß
beim immer so ein normaler schluss ger
naja viel spaß beim morgigen video beim
morgigen video genau genommen sonntags
video und viel spaß beim anschauen von
samira kleine sequenz das passt also bis
zum nächsten mal
die kinder warten
ich finde ich lebte und mit dem klub
seine mittäter sehe
ich hab taschentücher dabei und ein
geldbeutel und ein
die tempo und ein appell ich möchte
danke hält
online
ein apfel weil dann nämlich um habe im
klub und da bin ich in bochum ein apfel
verfalls von meiner mama meint es
nämlich lila und ich zeig euch jetzt
nochmal nerven was ich im club gekauft
und jetzt noch weh tut und wie dein
kuchen